hey uk it's gary vaynerchuk uh super
excited about being at vaynerworld this
year
really really hope you can come out and
join me uh a full day of like keynotes q
a book signings as a lot of you know a
lot of maniacs know i don't get out into
london
as often as i'd like so i hope you uh
join me this holiday season
um i'm gonna bring in my all and i
really really really hope you join me uh
you know what you can expect is just a
ton of engagement
um yeah i mean you guys know what i'm
about if you're watching this video you
have a pretty good sense of how i roll
i'm basically going to put on the
greatest event in london history and i
don't give a crap about
beatles or rolling stones or clash i'm
talking you know beckham i'm talking
global ever
the single great not the single best
business book event
the single greatest event
getting a little hyperbole but the
reality is this
i think a lot of contemporary american
businessmen
underestimate how incredible the london
market is i'm very flattered to be there
i'm very flattered to engage and talk
about agency world brand world
startup world small business world it's
all covered in jab jab jab
right hook um and since the you know
modern day heavyweight champion
lennox lewis ends up being the modern
heavyweight champion and so
it feels appropriate to put a huge event
in the uk
in london hope you schlep out listen
this is a european thing if you're
watching this like you know
with all the train infrastructure you
guys have i wish we had that here we
should get you to train to chicago nate
you know get there quickly the train
infrastructure in europe i hope you uh
hope you schlep out and join me
take a pic ask me a question um pick up
the book but more importantly just
engage
and hug it out and so i hope i see you
there